9-1-1 what's your emergency i got a left
driver that decided he would just drop
me off at a fuller station and he wants
me to get out
and i'm not getting out of the car all
because i asked him to put the window up
but i'm not leaving he says i have to
get out of his car
or he's calling the police so i decided
to call for house okay
i mean technically it's his property and
you have a civil agreement there's no
crimes involved
i am not going to allow him to leave me
on the side of the road
i pay for i pay for a ride and
he canceled it his key says he canceled
it yeah
so i'm just gonna sit here until he
sends me another ride you can order
another ride
so i can have an officer come out but
they're not going to be able to make him
stay there
well i mean he can't go anywhere because
i'm not moving until another car comes
so
so i get officers come out where are you
i'm not apparently i'm at the chef rod
in one city in richfield what's your
name
my name is joanne hardistuk all right
well officers come out
all right thank you bye